So let's now get to Donald Trump's Minnesota
rally on Friday night.
This one was bizarre and surreal.
One such surreal moment was Donald Trump still
unaware that Ruth Bader Ginsburg had died.
Starts talking about the Supreme Court.
And you can actually hear people in the background
yelling, Ginsburg is dead.
People in the crowd who have heard the news
on their phone, for example.
You're actually going to hear is Donald Trump
is just sitting up there like a fool ranting
about the Supreme Court.
You will he because it's so quiet, because
the crowd doesn't know what to make of these
bizarre rants by Donald Trump.
You can actually pick out.
You'll hear two female voices about 10 seconds
in and then a male voice about 30 seconds
in yelling Ginsburg is dead.
Totally surreal.
People on the stage behind Trump starting
to look around.
As news starts to spread.
And that's why the Supreme Court is so important.
The next president will get one, two, three
or four Supreme Court justices.
I had heard many presidents have had none.
They've had none because they're there for
a long time.
They tend to be appointed young.
They're there for a long time.
But the next one will have anywhere from one
to four.
Think of that.
That will totally change when you talk about
life, when you talk about Second Amendment.
When you talk about things that are so important
to you, you're going to be stuck for 40 years,
35 years, a long time.
So this is going to be the most important
election, in my opinion.
Just surreal is the only word I can think
of to describe this environment.
Trump earlier in the rally going on an unusual
screed about how Robert E. Lee would have
won the civil war had it not been for Gettysburg.
Trump outrageously praising the top general
in the fight to maintain slavery in the United
States during the Civil War.
And he was getting beaten a lot by Robert
E. Lee.
They want to rip the statue down all over
the place.
But Robert E. Lee, Robert E. Lee was a whether
you like him or not, whether you like statues
or not, you know, they don't rip statues down
anymore.
I signed the law ten years in jail.
But Robert Healy won many, many battles in
a row, and it was supposed to be over in one
day.
It was supposed to end immediately because
the north was too powerful for the south.
But it just shows when you have leaders, when
you have a great general and Robert Lee, he
would've won except for Gettysburg, and that
was because his general was killed.
Who's going to lead Gettysburg?
Never fight uphill.
My boys never fight uphill.
He heard they were going uphill.
Stop them.
But we had no cell phones.
And that day, right, congressmen?
No cell phones.
So they sent the horses to stop him.
Stop him.
But it was too late.
They fought uphill and they got slaughtered.
That's what happened.
But Robert E. Lee.
These were incredible things.
And then you might have noticed they're on
top of just a ridiculous, outrageous message.
Donald Trump slurring his way through this
one as well.
Gettysburg, as you heard, there are Trump
early in the rally did some pretty direct
racist red meat.
Here he is talking about whether people are
enjoying having refugees around, particularly
odd because at least some of these refugees
came in during Donald Trump's presidency.
This is part of Donald Trump running on changing
the country, even though he's been president
for the last four years.
One of the most vital issues in this election
is the subject of refugees.
You know it.
You know it perhaps better than almost anybody.
Lots of luck.
You having a good time with the Jews?
It's good.
We want to Omar.
He said, Oh, that's a beauty.
How the hell did you win the election?
How did she win?
These are rallies unlike anything we've seen
in American history, outside obscure white
nationalist KKK type candidates and authoritarian
dictators in the 20th century, mostly in other
countries.
That's what these rallies remind me of.
Trump seems completely unaware that he's the
incumbent rather than an outsider.
He keeps talking as if winning in November
would be a change in leadership.
He's been president for four years.
Is going a win so much.
And you're going to send Jason to the U.S.
Senate.
And you're going to keep winning and winning
and winning.
You're going to win on trade.
You're going to win on the military.
You're going to win on everything you touch.
Minnesota is going to keep on winning.
And you're going to get tired of winning because
Minnesota doesn't want to win all the time.
Your football team is going to win in the
Big Ten.
They say, no, we're going to keep on winning
in Minnesota and you're going to get so tired.
You're going to say, Jason.
Jason, please, please just go to the president
and see him in the Oval Office.
So if that topic is interesting to you, Trump
running as if someone else has been president.
Check out my YouTube clip from a couple of
weeks ago called Trump Running As If someone
else has been president.
And then again, Donald Trump raising this
idea of so-called patriotic education.
It's still not totally clear what it means,
but it's certainly not good.
We will stop the radical indoctrination of
our students and restore patriotic education
to our schools.
We will teach our children to love our country,
honor our history, and always respect our
great American flag.
This continues to play on the notion that
education is some kind of left wing indoctrination.
Instead of just recognizing the reality that
the more people know how to think, the more
people have critical thinking and epistemology
skills, the less likely they are to fall for
the bamboozling of Donald Trump and the Republican
Party.
Trump at one point urged the my pillow guy,
Mike Lyndell, to run run for governor of Minnesota.
He'll just tell him I'm very unhappy.
Right.
This is what these guys are.
Good businessman, by the way.
These guys right here, Mike.
They might be better than you.
I don't even know.
He may be the next governor.
You know, Mike Ladell, maybe you should run.
You should run.
That's another one of those moments where
Trump is saying.
Let me put it this way.
Let me back up.
Put it a different way.
When Trump says something this crazy, 20 percent
of what sick is that?
Trump is saying it.
80 percent of what sick is that?
The crowd claps and that the crowd will go
forever.
Anything Trump says.
Trump then told a totally incoherent story,
the likes of which we would normally hear
from like some drunk guy at a bar.
So I said to the general, I said, General,
five point seven billion B and not a billion.
That sounds very high to me, General.
I bought a lot of plans in my life and a lot
of helicopters.
I know a lot about it.
How could it be five, sir?
That's the best price they could get.
We only have one day to do it.
I said cancel it, General.
Cancel the order.
It was signed, actually.
Yes, sir.
I said, you have the right to catch you.
Yes, sir, I do.
We negotiated a great deal, I said.
Trump has this uncanny ability to get these
crowds to be completely silent.
During a strange stories in this clip, Trump
still seems confused about whether stealth
planes are literally invisible to the naked
eye rather than just being invisible to radar.
They're bigger.
They're more powerful, they're smarter.
And I like Tom Cruise.
By the way, because, I mean, you can't get
much better than Top Gun, right.
Great movie, right.
Get get better.
I like doctors, but these guys are better
looking than they got the crewcut.
They got that crap under their eyes.
They got the whole deal as smart as hell.
So I said, so, captain, let me ask you, how
good is the F-35?
That's at best play.
Oh, great.
I said, how do you compare that with what
Russia has?
Well, ours is better for a specific reason,
sir.
You can't see it.
What does that mean?
Well, when we fight, they cannot see us.
We are so stealth.
Now, that doesn't mean in three years that
it won't be obsolete because that's what happens.
That's a problem with a business.
Of course, military equipment getting obsolete.
It's a it's actually a feature of the military
industrial complex.
And then Trump slurred his way through, telling
the crowd that he could be living a luxurious
life right now, but instead he's sitting in
an airport hangar with these people.
All right, good.
Right now, we have a very beautiful life of
luxury.
And here I am at a hangar in Minnesota with
fifteen or twenty or twenty five thousand
four.
And thousands of people that couldn't get
in and I'm working my ass off, I could be
at home having a good time.
Wonderful.
But the one thing I say, this is just complete
cognitive dissonance.
Trump telling the crowd, I could be at my
penthouse instead of with you people.
And they cheer.
We love Trump.
Amazing.
And this isn't all of it.
We will be looking after the break at one
more rally
in Nevada.